In any school, it's vital that kids feel
safe and valued. These are among the
laudable goals of social and emotional
learning, or SEL. But SEL advocates need
to keep in mind some crucial cautions.
Here are two: One, promoting student safety
should not turn into an excuse to push
an agenda. Some SEL proponents seem
particularly taken with "restorative
justice" and tend to overstate the
evidence that it "works." Students should
feel safe and valued, and strategies to
make that happen should be held to a
consistent empirical standard. Two, Concern
for the emotional well-being of students
cannot become a free pass for academic folly.
It's healthy and natural for
parents and teachers to care how
children are doing socially and
emotionally. But, ultimately, schools must
be places of learning. SEL must remain
tightly linked to a focus on how kids
are doing academically. Absent these
considerations, SEL risks becoming more
about adult agendas than about what kids
need. Do you think that school improvement
efforts usually serve the needs of adults
or kids? Let us know in our poll.
Also, let us know what other
topics you'd like our scholars to cover
in 60 seconds and be sure to LIKE and
subscribe for more research and videos from AEI.